it would be really beautiful to talk
about where we were
back 16 years ago
it was a really interesting time we were
breaking some ground in some way I think
that we when we started I think Amores
Perros and Chronos were the first movies
to be and women competition in time back
then we Alfonso you started working in
the industry in a in a very strong way
but none of these things were done by
Design I think people think of a career
as something that you plan what they
just happened to us
we were just looking for a way to make a
movie so where where were we you wanna
talk about where we 16 years ago when we
were first together at the Oscars with
the Panzer oven
you you know with a Babel right yes well
where are you let's talk about where
where are we back then
where we were emotionally spiritually
geographically yes yeah every week I was
I was on my first marriage
New Year's commitment was to lose 20
pounds
I gained 200 pounds on my second
marriage so it's extremely important to
say what did happen in those 16 years
well I think it's uh a lot has happened
in the sense that
alham in many ways uh when you did that
film Babel it was the end of a search of
a certain kind of language in cinema
before you kind of made a a transition
and you you decide to go back and shoot
something in Spanish to do beautiful
um
at that time you you have done a modest
purpose of course and then you did 21
Grams
and then you're going to do this
keep on exploring the triptych format
but in this more way more ambitious kind
of canvas uh
the uh you I guess how was at that time
how did you feel yourself
as a filmmaker
um I think I was kind of I knew that it
was a good moment to end something that
I have in a way explore to the end of
what I could explore
and I knew that it was the beginning of
something that I need to start it
so it was a paradox moment in a way that
the film got attention and nominations
but deep inside me I knew that it was
the end of the story
so in a way you have to pretend that
yeah this is great but I knew that I was
about to start something that I didn't
have one clue about what to do next and
what I wanted but I knew that I was it
was the end of that language or that
format that I felt already
comfortable and you needed to reinvent
it exactly I I knew that I needed to
reinvent it and I was
more so it was like a you know so in a
sick of that so I I was in that moment
artistically that's where I was from I
that what it was going in inside of me
you know it's different because you said
you you were kind of already
a stopped of what you've been doing yeah
and well with you is different because I
think that with Pan's Labyrinth uh after
having done a after Chronos and and and
doing surviving mimic surviving mimic
and Devil's Back Devil's backblade
Etc
yes where
you you you've got the security to take
something I take all the elements and
all the all the learning curve that you
have achieved with all the Ambitions
that you had in terms of conveying
cinematically and all the different
things that you've wanted to convey and
and that was the moment in which you did
Pan slattering you know it's funny
because what happens is you guys
you learn to use certain technical
elements because you did commercials or
you did Big movies and I was uh I never
did play with toys and I remember
shooting with Guillermo Navarro we were
shooting a spinos Diablo Devil's
Backbone and there's a shot where the
kids turn and hear an explosion and we
were pushing with a dolly past their
faces I was like no no no closer and
again says you're thinking of a
technocrine shot and I said oh I will
use it on the next movie and I use the
Techno on Blade 2 and I used a bunch of
things I haven't simulated digital
effects had come to be something that I
got to know very well and I said what if
I apply all that to a personal movie
which we did together
yes we I was lucky that I was hoping I
remembered last the first time that you
uh that you told me this story we were
we were at your house and you we are
having chicken soup yes yeah and I said
and let me tell you the movie from
beginning to end and when it ended we
started we were crying you know we will
really move them
they're saying something but I know what
it says it's like yes you'll come back
welcome back we'll come back after this
message no
uh uh
Alejandro's film career right now in
this in this clip but I want to say
something before the clip
a clip is boring everybody can see it no
it's because I realized that
um that that in a way that film in that
year for you you got to Spain you do a
film in Spanish
and in a way it's funny that we will
talk about that if you will like he's
the host but I just want to say that
it's funny that
that in order to move forward we have to
go back you understand I mean I think
for me in the moment that I was saying I
have just realized that by the way that
I was feeling that I need to go to
another place I went to do a film in
Spanish
not in Mexico all the time but in Spain
so I went back to something that I
needed from my roots to my understanding
in order to move forward and I think the
films run my way in order for you to
move forward with what you have been
doing you have to go to your past and to
your roots and I think that's a very
interesting uh kind of similar path
right which can we see your clip now I'm
really scared but okay let's see they're
gonna be a part let's see it let's see
you know the films is that there's
almost like a same theme that goes that
threats to through throughout all the
films obviously one important aspect is
that
uh metaphorically or literal death
uh that that you've been exploring since
since your first film and uh sometimes
again it's a it's a it's a literal death
uh
or the closeness to that death but in
most of the cases is that is combined
with the end of the Journey of a
character
so how it seems where do you think that
comes from
I think come from from a very uh very
primal
um
fear uh and Consciousness that we all
share that is that no matter which race
nationality and rich or whatever
political belief uh we all will die so
we always since I was a kid I was always
thinking we all here in this theater
once we will become and when I was
watching these followers of my family in
the early and they were like and I was
asking my father I mean this guy oh he's
gone
so in a way when you start conscious
that sometimes you will be in that
picture
um anyway suddenly for me to to have the
opportunity to imagine your own death
and to imagine how you can tell that
story from that perspective make it
sometimes a little bit not more about
City but a little bit more profound
the meanings or whatever is priority
comes out a little bit
clear
and so in a way I I would think that we
all when we confront weakness or
fragility or things like that is when
our biggest character or flaws come out
and the analysis of a character from
there from himself observing that life
that he went through that is like to use
fiction or art to talk about that and
he's not just about that because I'm
interested I think the departure is from
Death that's the foundational in a way
is true a pattern that I have but I
think from that uh great uh place from
in the stadium of life you can see clear
uh above a much more broader
in order to talk about law to talk about
um uh time to talk about art
and uh and and and fatherhood and and
lots so all those things suddenly come
out in a much more pristine and Powerful
way so in a way yeah it's something that
I think is a pattern but maybe that's
the way I can probably I'm I'm trying to
understand the reason but maybe that's
one of the reasons because something
that the films of the two of you they
have in common and more if if uh if
people get to know you guys is how
deeply even obliquely deeply of
biographic along with them are
you know they're they're expressing
specific moments in your lives
the uh uh and and the specific quests
that you have in life in those specific
moments in in which you do those films
and for me it's an uh is what makes you
feel so powerful because they are so
infused by emotion and experience
so I I don't know how conscious you are
about that when you're doing your films
Alejandro but is a a they are very very
present about that moment in time when
you shot them
yes I I think uh we all I think and
every artist in a way if you are a
filmmaker or a musician or a writer or
whatever you do I think no matter what
uh whatever you put out there is gonna
be a next Ray of your emotional state
your circumstances will be expressed
there even if you read Even If you deny
them or you want to suppress them that
suppression of emotional thing you will
come out and said I was so suppressed
and I was so disoriented or I was so
lost
so in a way yes I think all these films
I cannot even see them because when I
see them I feel I I sometimes I want to
see things that I don't want to remember
or want to I mean though those films in
a way represent the time in a life
um and and and I remember things that I
was and when you are evolving or you
know sometimes you are going backwards
uh but whatever it just reminds you so
yes they expressed that and emotionally
they have some intensity that sometimes
I don't recognize so what I'm saying I
could not shoot I'm always I recognize
yeah thank you everything he says is
intense
shut up
about making guacamole he says and then
you take the avocado
gives you his life
and avocado is born and before and
before I finish the avocado he ate it
that's why I'm so intense about it now
now I think I want a dog well they're
saying something but I want a doctor
okay okay let they want to show the real
of the year so let's go okay yes yes can
I say something before so I can do
defense yeah yeah no two things I want
to talk about the fact that back in that
moment and you were in your third
reinvention when when we were doing
children of man and I want to talk about
it when we come back and about about
transformation what I will say before we
see it there have been a couple of times
in my life shape of water and Panasonic
I thought because people see them and
what is he gonna do next no one knows
what's gonna happen your last film is
your last film and uh I both times I
thought this is the last movie I make I
I don't want to do anymore I I we talk
about it all the time that's it I'm done
and I put everything on it and then
something happens that is beautiful but
that movie uh you you say that all the
time and you tell me I'm going to do
only one one and that's it and so yeah
oh but you're prepping another one oh
yes wait wait today today the year all
the time said that this is the last and
today he was telling me already three
Pro in there
I told you something that made me laugh
because it's like you know Mexican we
said okay the last drink the last drink
when your friend sat down you know that
is two bottles next
well ladies
[Laughter]
[Applause]
I think everybody knows about your love
for the general and uh and how you
commit that you have been to it in in
different shapes that form you know
going more into sometimes more science
fiction sometimes more fantasy
but but but always very deeply rooted
there
Alejandro there are things that go
throughout all of your filmography yeah
you know not only uh images but it seems
yeah which ones you recognize well I
recognize too one of them is the the
virtue of this obedience
which I think is vital to be the Soviet
history to be a thinking person
you know and I think the other one is
the absolute inalienable right
to be [ __ ] up it would be imperfect
which I defend I think that imperfection
is one of the most beautiful things
fallibility and Perfection and that's
why I I I think those themes are very
well represented in the monster
and or in in the fear and death like
Alejandro I think I've been thinking
about dying since I was seven
I've been like I've been like death
groupie and I went like come on come on
it's like everybody waits for David
Bowie to come to town I'm waiting for
death you're like come on man
because I think it
all the sense
it makes life make sense
I really I really believe that and that
also is you said to me one day he said
shut up you're very carefully everybody
in your movies dies to be happy
you were not wrong I don't think you
were wrong about that is there's
something very I'm a Labs Catholic but a
Catholic and a lot of the imagery and
the resurrection like Pinocchio is like
the Jesus it's like Christ is made of
wood is has Nails resurrects three times
to save those that he loves the the
character in Chronos is called Jesus
Greece Jesus gray he resurrects the
resurrection death uh family
father figures well but now you're
coming out of the closet because you
were used to deny those things oh yeah I
know yeah the older I get the less I I
the more I accept that things must be
fascinating there that that I'm okay
with I mean I I grew up with Catholic
cosmology and I love it I I think it's a
mythology that is built in my bones you
know well but the thing is because it's
very obvious in one hand is the monster
yeah yeah and monster meaning yes but
because you know like like in even in
your Noir is another approach to deal
with the monster yeah yeah and that's
why he says you're no good and that's
why and I know because neither am I I
think that I think that if we if we
stopped I think the most tyrannical
[ __ ] thing we invented is nice
the tyranny of nice [ __ ] jokes man
you know I I think that everybody is
we're all complex people we are all
paradoxical people 9 am you're saying 9
30 you're an [ __ ] 10 30 you're a
great father 11 45 you're a bad son and
that's you you know you you can be you
should be every color in the rainbow you
shouldn't be black or white and I think
the monster is that is uh imperfection
is beautiful well but just this monster
is specifically in your film
One More Time same as Alejandro they're
very autobiographical yes and sometimes
uh literally in the sense of
autobiography of
stuff brooded deeply rooted in your
memories as a child yes but sometimes
it's also the moments that you're living
and either to say sometimes those
10 those monsters in some instances
they always are kind of almost
oblique portraits of yourself physically
yeah I'm talking about physically well
like boys most of them like my voice is
most of my monsters I make the voice of
the the monsters in bangladian time
Pacific Rim and then
etc etc I tried to make the voice of the
monsters
The Ghost and there was vagma and and I
think it's I completely uh identify as
that and I and I felt when I was born
and I saw Frankenstein I said that's
that's my Jesus right there you know
that's that's what I believe in that's
my saint no but you know
for more monster that you want to be
you have upon you you I have a bad news
for you Kevin you are very nice here
be nice with his super nice that's your
punishment let's talk about Alfonso
I was going to say is that in a
we go way back way back and he will even
we're going to go back like back 150
pounds yeah
more or less yeah uh but even we go even
further back in the sense that
we later on discovering life that we
have been in the same place watching the
same exactly the same the same films uh
when we were children yeah and and those
films that we happen to be watching at
the same time in the same place uh that
by the way
they were in great Indie in yourself
obviously I knew but it even in me
because immediately we start talking
about those and some are most of them
were Monster films some other light
Melody I love Melody yeah he's not so
well known
yeah uh but the um
it these monsters I mean a lot of them
were some were Santo Santo controls
you know for wrestler films with
Monsters uh but but there were other
ones that they were used I I think that
in that time in Chapala was
uh
I don't know if it was a werewolf film
or I don't remember if it was the
werewolf yes or girlfriend yeah it was
that one right yeah yeah so it was uh
and we didn't know he vacation in a lake
near my hometown and we ended up
watching the same movies in a little
Cinema there together we didn't know
each other what there you go anyway so
now let's uh why don't we switch to
Alejandro of course
again
we're going to see a thing from Bardo
his latest film yes
[Applause]
I'm very happy we started with uh
you you're showing this this clip
because first of all it's an amazing
opening of an incredible film
the first shot itself
in many in many ways and encompasses so
much of of
of your thematic kind of uh search
um
and life is this uh and yes this is true
it's not in terms of the Thematic
thinking he's filmed but the way that
you are as a person yeah and that's what
I wanted to come back into that that
in sometimes more obliquely sometimes
more directly the the your films guys
the two of you are always a reference of
of who you guys are
and uh YouTube
well probably but this about you two
guys the
this thing of a character who wants to
take off
to that he went a character who's uh
wants to to fly
but nevertheless reality like the error
keeps on dragging him back you know and
and this is a lot of of what you do is
that state in that struggle of those uh
of those big jumps trying to trying to
to fly trying to achieve
a some sort of some sort of freedom and
Liberation but it's open right back into
into the Earth yeah
yeah I think um I think we are not we
all like that in a way I think that um
this is a very recurrent dream that I
have had many times in my life by
periods in my life not all the time but
sometimes when it appear appear many
times in a couple of weeks and then it
goes for seven years and it arrives
again and it's always like that it's
like this flying that it's very close to
the ground
and there's something very satisfying
and pleasant but at the same time
something very dangerous that any little
bad move can really just drag me to
death
and but generally it's a pleasant thing
and and there's a sensation that I
sometimes can get up a little bit more
but then there's something grounding me
and um so I I I when I was thinking and
developing this that came as the natural
with no thinking as a subconscious image
that came up and I knew that that was
the beginning and it was not a
rationality and the ending at the ending
because but the funny thing is that it
was a scene as many other sequins that
appear with no signs of rational
intelligence or agenda or to be part of
this puzzle it was just naturally came
and I knew that it was the beginning how
or why I didn't know
but I think came from a very deep
subconscious Revelation which was
meaningful for the reasons that you said
about this struggle that we will have to
you know our life are always going from
the most Sublime
intentions and thoughts and actions
sometimes and then we are grounded in
our own PDT and pathetic things and and
these kind of struggle all the time of
trying to get to something and we can't
that's that sometimes and then at the
same time for me was very clear that
that was I even when I was starting the
the the the script and I didn't know
exactly where I gonna arrive
I knew that emotionally or the the
essence of the film was this so I mean
again even without having many other
things
I always feel that in the first two
minutes of the film you understand who
you are with in which hands you are and
what the film is about I think the first
time who's the director exactly so I
mean you you see two minutes and you
know exactly where you are because I
mean it's gonna be hard to get you know
that like taste the wine you you do it
and you said oh it's bad no it's you
don't need too much or to listen a song
the same but I knew that that was the
film that I wanted to make and I want to
get the people into that
phantasmaloric because I feel that the
film was a fantasmagoric uh way of a
character that is disappearing in the
last migration from the that death of
his Consciousness so that was for me was
something that was so crucial to make
this and this we have to make it like
four times because it was so difficult
to make this I mean it's incredible it
was so difficult and I have it in my
mind we storyboard everything but then
how to do it technically it took us a
year to really nail it how to make that
happen so anyway it was some Obsession
and I'm glad that you like it because
it's the essence of the film yeah but
it's just the the the opening of
something that then it goes in America I
have to say it's very courageous your
film yeah uh because in you without
being about you you're exposing so much
about yourself
you know there is is uh this whole thing
the opening the the next scene in the
hospital with the with the baby doesn't
want to come out that end up with this
another one of my favorite moments in
your film is that tiny that tiny baby
going into the sand like a little turtle
and going back into
the ocean you know almost as a as a new
life you know and uh but what you've
been doing more and more ever since
probably the as we're we're talking
about different periods of transitions
that we have in our in our in our films
uh that I'm sure very likely coincide
with our lives
uh there was a big switch after
beautiful and with Birdman you start
becoming more
not only instinctual as you're saying
you know a but also humorous more humor
a lot more humor much more humorous but
also it comes with age
not caring so much about trying to give
a direct explanation of of of what the
movie was about is about the one thing
represents
and I think that that's uh and and this
an embargo is you just took that all the
way I mean it's very courageous because
as filmmakers we are always uh a bit
concerned about
not having a safety net
you know and a safety net can be
expressed in different ways as a safety
net can be a narrative safety net you
know some kind of traditional story that
falls in three acts and that you you you
know where you are at in this story yeah
I think that for me this film
differently from others this is a very
particular unique film that demanded
from me much more than any other one
because it it needs to come from a very
prospective thing which I think age has
to do a lot this this white bird in a
way has some benefits not many but maybe
that one is one that you become a little
bit more doesn't suit yourself
I don't have to shave it but uh now that
is here I can talk about the there's no
in my face
um but I have to say that age in a way I
could have not made this film
um I will not be ready five years ago or
ten years ago because in a way all these
things that come from a very deep
personal experiences some of them more
than factual things yes are identify
occupuntarily in the emotional moments
that I consider that were crucial as the
one that opened the scene my wife Maria
which is here tonight and uh we we lost
our son our Second Son Luciano right
after he born and then
um you know we went to a very traumatic
and fragile moment that's only when you
are young you lost something and that is
present so fast and unexpectedly or
natural that that Mark and then
um we have a
Second Son which is here to Eliseo which
is a beautiful and unfortunately he he
came alive from something that was
similar to his brother who has the same
disease and we went through 11 months
after that
to a very traumatic one-month in
intensive care with him in a life and
death situation so in one year we were
dealing with the dead or the possible
death of these two people those human
beings that we love more than anything
and that carry on us True Life True at
least for me and my wife in a very
conscious kind of possibility of that
and there's a moment that After Time
after therapy or after all the pain that
you start to process in a way time
allows you to start thinking about those
moments in another way and even humor
can be allowed but that for that to
happen you need a lot of maturity this
little love to work on deeply and
suddenly understand that those kind of
things life and that are out of your
head yeah but in this in this film you
were completely bare about it and even
if you the relationship something
touches me the most
is the the family relationship but but
what I'm saying is that suddenly
I felt the need to surrender to all the
things that I was kind of protecting and
suddenly the bless of this film for for
all of us I think for me and for as a
family is that there are some things
that you keep
and then when you surrendered and let it
go and I think art exists because life
is [ __ ] up for all of us it's not
perfect it's not enough and art allows
you to in a way
you know poetry music art in a way
allows us to to get to get something out
of pain and and liberate pain in a way
that I try to True humor
and through a metaphor and through a
symbolic like an allegory so this film
for me is an allegory of my own life
which is not real is not factual but
it's a fictionalized way for me to
liberate a lot of things shame uh pain
doubt uh doubt fear
and and but with the fictional elements
of the human things and the most
beautiful reward that I have had in this
film is that all these themes about
family about fatherhood about loss of of
family members
um I have found in in screenings people
that when they see this uh scene because
most of us have lost somebody that we
love
they make their their own and they feel
liberated and they feel a way that Let
It Go such a pain and that was the
exercise that I did with this as an
exercise thing and that's why movies
support me that's the way it's a
cathartic thing so that was the exercise
and I think humor as you were saying is
key because without humor I will not
survive that that you cannot you know
what I mean and again it's a position
that I have in my life thankfully that
and I said that these film is snorkeling
other films I always put people in the
dark I mean the diving kind of thing and
I was you know block you know pressuring
a lot and I think in this film I wanted
to be a snorkeling that you can be
snorkeling and see the depth but from
the light and from the safe net from the
water and see the Sun and then the grace
and then the dark but from that
perspective that's the way I think life
is we can navigate through pain but I
think always there is light that that's
the way I feel
okay
okay so now let's look at the scene of
Pinocchio why are you I'm not sorry
you know if if it was not yet
yeah anybody that seen since the film
would think it's somebody else yeah okay
yeah buddy
it's like somebody else's film that's
the idea yeah now did you choose that
scene sorry did you choose the Sim the
truth the thing that they showed did you
choose it it's in the film no no what I
mean I don't know what the [ __ ] we're
gonna look at oh
yeah but I don't know what uh
sorry
the movie comes from the same man I mean
we have similarities
everything that you learn about being a
son and being a father
you try to it becomes the most uh what
occupies your mind the most
after 40. his fatherhood and being a son
and learning that your father didn't
know he was a father he was just a guy
but for you he was your father and and
you cannot understand that you are a
father to someone that you're a shadow
in their lives and I tried to make sense
of that and and many things and and to
put things that hurt and are beautiful
to me the the most beautiful thing I've
ever written is the final line what
happens happens and then we're gone and
to me is the essence of the one thing I
have learned in 58 years that you know
is this little time we have for each
other that is important but that's
something that both demographies that
you you have in common it could describe
his movie what happens happens it is and
I think there is a lot of
self-reflection in movies right now I
think there are a lot of people that are
either looking towards their biography
in films uh be it Empire of light or be
it uh
and the fablements are made whatever you
want people are looking back and
Armageddon time I mean these are because
we are in a moment of self-reflection as
a race
I really think we are wondering where
we're going
I think that we are wondering uh and and
the movies again have an imperfection
it's about as the cricket says about
imperfect fathers and imperfect zones
because if we do allow that if we allow
that room to breathe to each other
I think we can live but if we demand the
Perfection or authority or like no one
is a father no one is a father even if
you are a father you are a fallible
person and when you understand that and
I I lost my dad after a shape of water
on my mom right before you know guilt
and then I was able to see them as
people as you know neither Saints nor
Devils they were just people that
happened to me my father and the other
the openings you know part of reminds me
of something my mom said she said you
were a disease of nine months and I come
by lessons of a lifetime
and she has to pay this ecology for 20
years
therapy is 20 years no but I but I think
I think the
the the the every movie
since then I went I thought about them
in terms of almost like musical like I
thought shape of water was a song
you know I thought uh nightmare rally
was this sort of dirge you know and I
think Pinocchio is it really tries to be
a little phrase of love it is one of the
movies that was done with the most loved
Michael Stefan my co-producers my
everybody that animated the movie
everybody gave the movie is made with so
much love and passion and it took so
long to make that I think it is very
transparent that it's there it's a very
healing movie for me I still cry with it
well it's for you and for and for many
people yeah for us
yeah and that's that's I think is is uh
in the movie is such a beautiful when I
came up with the idea of Pinocchio
having a dialogue with death
I thought that that was when the movie
appeared for me I thought this is it's
about that it's about opening the way we
close with a little pine cone and I knew
that the final note of Grace of the
movie was going to be the Pinecone
falling
when he says what happens happens and
then we're gone you know and and and he
says almost like a musical sense and
your movie is also very musical but
that's that's the thing but both films
normally in terms of of how things are
transient but also in the in the the
relationship
they they
fact the need of of fathers to infuse
their sons with their own fears and
their insecurities or their
understanding trying to mold
try to mull who the child is going to be
to discover in both films
the the voice of the of the children but
the child is is already a miracle I mean
this is the thing this is a guy that
prays for a miracle gets a miracle and
doesn't recognize it which is what
happens to every one of us every day of
every moment of our life Miracles come
in horrible shapes
horrible shapes in perfect shapes the
kid is already born the way the
Pinocchio is and this is the only
Pinocchio movie that I know that the one
learning is Geppetto has not been okay
learning to be a real boy but they're
better than learning to be a real father
and that was that's that was very
important for me and I think that one of
the most for me moving things in your
movie is that uh first of all that is
handmade
not really is I mean is that the
craftsmanship that is there it feels
like from another period when films were
done not with CEI and [ __ ] like that
like human fingers and and really it's a
crap that is human as hell
and we and the other thing the decision
you made of leave pinocho with a piece
of wood that you didn't put the blue
eyes of Disney and the guy doing that
like pinocho is a piece of wood and you
said you're scared
but what I'm saying is like these kind
of
the fact that he leave a piece of wood
yeah in the bad shape naked and
unfinished that's a naked unfinished
that I think you said when I say Porky
Pig I say why doesn't he wear pants this
guy really likes comfort
but that was a very brave decision that
you made it that because with that with
that decision I think you said it all so
I mean in a way that you leave that
piece of wood that becomes more and more
dear endearing and at the end you are
completely moved with no need of makeup
as it is I think that was a very very
brave decision but I want to talk about
this guys
it's okay the memo Three Amigos and this
[ __ ]
is
[Applause]
because in pinoculars besides the and we
will talk about the the graphics in both
have amazing collaborators thank you
okay in terms of the crap they crap from
[ __ ] but something about Pinocchio is
that and it's so great that it's
happening and it's amazing what is
happening right now with the bastards
you know which is it has been
shortlisted shortlisted yeah but but
it's considered like as it should be I
mean I think that these all definitions
about what is a a feature film a short
film what is uh uh an information what
is not animation and stuff is a film
and is this is what matters
is being recognized as adapted
screenplay production design yeah sound
sound music yeah you know it's it's
filling all the the categories of is
just taking his own right as a film you
know it I think that the time has come
of of separate of of of delegating like
in a different category animation or
some stuff that is for children that
we're going to reward in a different in
a different way it is incredibly
incredibly
installed in the minds of a lot of
people that are in the movie business
that animation is a genre for kids and
it's not it's a medium and it's a medium
for creation of beauty and film and art
and
I think I think it's a battle that will
take years but we you know when you see
things like that are as perfect as any
major sake movie or the red turtle which
is an absolute Masterpiece or I lost my
body and you know that this medium is
not being used in all this potential and
and you know it's about I'll keep doing
well I think it's being juice I'm not
sometimes not recognized the way it
should be yeah this the same way that
for instance I think that Pinocchio has
one of the most one of the best
screenplays this year the production is
not not to talk about the production
design the music the lighting and the
way we we are we are lighting real sets
real props we are moving in linear way
from one side to the other a real
character that we're animating is you
know I think of a stop-motion like what
Ginger used to say about Fred Astaire we
do the same steps that you do but
backwards in high heels it's exactly the
same stop motion to live action we do
exactly this time not to mention the
performances yes I mean those that this
that's the clip that that showcases a
lot of failed gestures within
unnecessary little things that happened
to look like accidents jepetto sliding
stumbling kicking a bottle that's on the
floor we animate unnecessary things to
make it real yeah well and that's I know
we get there was directing you know is
that that that's also that speaking of
directing
you know we're talking about and we're
talking about you know and I think that
something are just afraid
and the Two Amigos continue
now uh
you you have shared some in this in this
specific case for instance now you
you're sure saying some mixers right
in we have the same mixers yeah the same
mixtures and that you work with uh every
time I was gonna mix pinoculars they say
can you give Alejandro two more days
every time
no but because the the thing is um there
are certain collaborators that
a the three they have been unlucky
enough that they have worked with the
three of us Kate Blanchette
yes production designer and pants
libraries
[Applause]
yeah uh that that I think that is it is
look all of this stuff that we're
talking about in many ways is are just
amazing ideas
uh if now is because of the involvement
of these these very important people
yeah that help to put all these Universe
this world together
so because it's uh and and something
that the two films they have in common
is is the amazing the beauty of the
craftsmanship and they grab my ship I'm
not talking just in terms of a technique
I'm talking about
the artistic approach the interpretation
of ideas
the not only the interpretation but the
the execution of ideas into something
concrete yeah and you have the amazing
work of Darius Congee that is uh uh an
amazing he's always been amazing but
this work is unlike any of the work that
that Darius has done yeah for for me I
think this film was very particular too
because I obviously as you in Roma I
returned to Mexico
and one enough I work with people that I
have never worked in my life because I
mean I suddenly returned to a country
that is not the one that I left I'm not
the guy that I left the country they
expect another guy that I'm not anymore
I expect another circumstances that they
don't exist
so in a way it became a battle kind of
thematically was very close to what the
character is going through and the
opportunity to work with this amazing uh
new family that we create for almost one
year and a half ago we did it in the
middle of the pandemic so to work with
the genio to anatarasas
custom designer designer was incredible
and and Darius for example and then
Nicolas Baker in the sound design and
every single Department was Martin
Martin was the only guy Martin
sang all my films but with Nico they did
that kind of and work with me on Ben
Simon which is amazing can you work with
you yeah yeah so another one another one
who survived
um but what I'm saying is
Survivor yeah you started I followed
anyway but a great actor I I think the
the the collaboration and as you were
saying for me suddenly to have the
opportunity to work with this you know
world-class uh the filmmakers artists
and to combine the way to see the film
at the same time
this film will have been completely
different with another team I know that
that whatever they put in it you know
that you said values the way he Paints
the things so it's such a difficult
thing to put everybody in the same
frequency that everybody's doing the
same film and I think I felt it I think
that we were also submerged in the in
the battle mode nobody read the script
everybody was just going through every
sequence everything and just guarding
the feeling of what the film needs and
in a way it was we were so aware and the
beauty of the only thing that was
beneficial for the film of the pandemic
is that we were going from our
apartments that we all were living alone
with no family with no nothing and it
was just completely concentrating in the
work so all of us the only thing that we
have to do is to work and we work
together through that and that was our
survival mode in the depression of the
of the situation and that was very very
beautiful but I think when people say
why the South America are doing which is
extremely hard to for people sometimes
to understand because they think oh he
does everything or he doesn't in those
days or that is is to create an
environment in which you do
self-portraiture
and you invite everybody to those
self-portraiture to to make the movie
their their self-portrait for the Darius
for the design of her and that's the
difference like how Daniel is different
in my movie than in your movie than in
your movie is a different production
designer in each of her movies but each
of them is serving at the end of the day
all of us are serving one single
portraiture the self-portraiture of the
movie and that's the beauty of the
director is the only one that
talks to the movie in a way like
directly and tries to invite everybody
to talk to it to to be part of that and
and I think these collaborators are
vital because they give boys to the
movie in different ways than you will
but but in Pinocchio that you're working
in a in stop-motion yes
that how big or how big was the biggest
uh model the biggest figure oh well
there was a pinocular that was this tall
it was just a chest top and there was a
cricket though okay but there you go you
have a different different scales yeah
what do you remember the list in each
one of those scales I have to say I
recognize
uh uh do we have a puppet here
no yeah we we we can recognize for
instance uh a certain that the lighting
of your films
follows a certain language
and pinocchiobin stop-motion and doing
it in scale yeah still replicates that
that that uh that language and with the
cinematography same with the production
design yeah and the the palace that
textures and everything that means that
there is an interpretation of ideas from
a group of craft runs yes yes
and they all end up talking to the movie
and doing self-portraiture you know from
the beginning only the director talks to
it and then you invite everybody come
and talk to the movie Let me now you
introduce them to the movie and
everybody starts talking to it and at
the end of the day
the mission was this and the reason one
of the reasons the movie took more than
15 years to get made ultimately but
about 10 or 11 years of rejections
everybody passed on this movie everybody
said no and part of the conversation was
that I said I'm not making a movie for
kids but kids can watch it very
different very bad salesman yeah very
much I know I I am I want I work with my
dad my dad had a car dealership and I
didn't sell a single [ __ ] car
because they would say is this a good
guy no
you know the same same thing here I I
would say and I I would say to to them
uh this is a movie that I want to live
next to Devil's background and Ben's
Labyrinth that's the movie I want to
make and and that I'm not making it for
kids doesn't mean kids cannot watch it
I'm not making a babysitter movie
where you plump the [ __ ] kid and for
two hours you forget about them you
gotta talk to the kids if they watch
this movie you're talking about drama or
the you know the hamster dying or
whatever the [ __ ] you know
and did you tell did you tell them that
it was not children's film yours
so for me to say nobody wants to make
this film obviously it was a film that I
didn't want anybody to read the script
it was a very personal and I went to the
useful suspects and you think that
because you have some awards and some
Oscars you will get the green light the
bad news is that that doesn't exist to
me
just for your uh pleasure this morning
one of my movies was turned down
it never stops
exactly so either way no matter how many
awards you have or Oscars this film was
rejected for two years and nobody wants
to do it and that's a good sign exactly
I think no I think that honestly Birdman
it's a good sign because you know that
you are doing something that is not like
that is not easy and Birdman was
something that I was reject two years
the same until some brave people got do
it and in this case it was Netflix but a
film in Spanish personal well that there
is like sequence dreamy there isn't a
story without story and everything's
Blends and time and about all these
themes and and I think I was really
lucky to really have uh Netflix behind
to give me the the the the the support
the budget and the freedom to make the
film that I wanted to do uh in a Spanish
with no International Film stars and I
think in your case all the challenge
that you have I think it made the film
better because the more time that I
spent trying to get the money that was
the time that I was really writing and
polishing the script and trying to you
know it in a way grow and grow and grow
and my anxiousness to do it it was
bigger so when I arrived to do it I was
more hungry you know in a way I think if
I would have get maybe the money
immediately it will not be as good as it
well you started you started to finance
the movie yourself sorry you finance the
movie I started financing my wife not
here to say you are crazy are we going
to sell the house it's true I mean I was
just going and going and spending money
there was a time that the when the
pandemic hit I couldn't really afford it
it was impossible so I mean it was a a
huge a huge decision and that
miraculously came the possibility to do
it with Netflix but I think the more you
struggle I think nowadays in my point of
view you have to have a need to make a
movie and you have to have to be brave
because we were talking about all the
challenges that are now are different
but are kind of the same challenges than
before so I mean the challenges will
always exist and always will be you know
suffering and uncertainty and challenges
the challenges of today are different
than maybe 20 years ago and 50 years ago
but our challenges and as a filmmakers
we all know I think there's a lot of
people that you we live for that you
have to have you know the challenge
doesn't mean that is wrong I think
challenge make you strong longer and I
have learned in Birdman and in this one
thanks for the challenge because that
made me better yeah and the the the the
challenge of the the loud how how loud
are the voices now that destroy you and
make us doubt and make us uncertain we
just have to be courage you know the
courage to be ready to be disliked and
to say the things that we need to say
the way we want to say it with no fear
of whatever they want to say or whatever
rejection rejection is actually exactly
it can be I like something very positive
I like I like it look at me I like
rejection
I like it Alexander stimulant
I I think for me it wasn't a stimulator
because I was saying what is wrong
because it's a laxative
[Laughter]
Imodium
it's I think it's true but anyway I
think that it says wrap up
hold on before we wrap up can I say
something to do first and to you both I
mean if we were supposed to talk about
ourselves and this and then on Three
Amigos and all that advertisement I want
to say to you I I admire the [ __ ] out of
you both of them
what is this about I think it's about
love because I love you and it's about
admiration because I admire you and you
inspire me every every year of my life
I've been and we've been together
professionally since the beginning of
her career and you have always inspired
me and you've always been a companion a
teacher and a brother
thank you
I I want to add I want to ask that home
that uh for me tell me about the avocado
you ate it you ate it my friend many of
them before I finished my avocado with a
tomato
I have to say that um
uh the way I met both of of them Alfonso
aguilliermo
it was through they start earlier than
than me they start to they have already
films already made when I was just even
thinking to start to make something of
one hour for a TV pilot that I wrote
and the the first thing that I did was
try to approach to Alfonso and I was
scared because he has he was already
preparing Great Expectations he was
living in the Chateau Marmont he was
already a big shot and I was just these
poor kind of you know guys
and the way he got me the way he
received me yeah
okay
they're gonna tease me but I have to say
that the way he became the way he
behaved generously
okay since the first moment he offered
me
um that hand and that advice truthful
tough and generous
and since that day in 1995 that has been
exactly the same and with Guillermo the
story you already know that you know the
editing Amore sparrows eight months and
lost in the thought he without knowing
me he went to my house flew from
Guadalajara from from us in Texas Texas
okay okay A little the ticket the league
the ticket was expensive but what I'm
saying is that he really helped me to
find out you know their final cut of
amorosperos and since then generally
generously has been basically the
pattern and for me the blessing in my
life as a as a filmmaker in such a
privileged job that we have but so tough
and sometimes so lonely to walk this
path
never lonely in your life always with
two friends that can hold you in failure
and can celebrate with you in success
stories for me these two guys without
them I will not exist guys
is going to do a live performance of
ciao Papa
[Laughter]
guys I really appreciate you coming here
thank you
thank you very much and uh hasta la
vista
thank you very much
[Applause]